you ever hear when a person that's
building a house brand new house they're
building it up and they go talk to the
general contractor and the contractor
says oh we can build this up in six
months and then 22 months later the
house is still not built why is that or
a person that's in their late 20s like i
want to get married early 20s still not
married i want to get married mid-30s
how come i'm married 38 years old just
the market you know i don't i don't know
i don't want to we're going to talk
about that today because there's a power
in choices pro and con i'll cover that
with you today and if it makes sense to
you give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel so let me get right into it
so
there is power in having options there
is power in having choices there is
power i like three choices when i buy
something give me three options and come
back to me this price this price this
price the one that's expensive offers a
lot more benefits the one that's cheap
they have only been out for six months
what do we want to do and we decide on
who we want to buy great you know
industries oh my gosh i'm 22 years old
what should i get involved in should i
go sell should i do real estate should i
do insurance should i do mortgage
digital marketing should i do a
pharmaceutical what do i do options
options options dating oh my gosh i got
four girlfriends it's so cool i got mary
jackie i got so ah i got so many options
because i got all these girls great
i don't know why the people
that have made it to the highest level
they are the ones that are early to
choose one thing and they make that one
thing their one and only option and they
make it work i've had four girlfriends
at the same time that i was talking to
and i was dating four in my early
twenties
i was the worst in my career at the time
because i was all over the place i was
so distracted trying to see what i'm
doing with everybody tracking everyone's
birthdays families it was a mess it
wasn't fun it wasn't exciting it was
cool but i wasn't winning i had i'm
doing this and i sell this and i sell
that and i do this this is not going to
work
everything changed for me when i went to
the power of one and i said i'm going
this industry and i'm going to give the
financial industry 20 years today's my
20-year anniversary while i'm shooting
this by the way today september 10th i
got involved in financial industry day
before 9 11. i said i'm going to go 20
years i was like what about this what
about that hey pat if you do mortgage
he's going to make an additional 50 000
a month not interested hey pat if you do
you know this you're going to make an
additional 100 000 a month not interest
why are you doing insurance it's such a
boring industry i'm doing insurance who
wants to do life insurance and annuities
me that's what i'm what about no one pat
nope my gosh pat is so hard-headed we
can't get him to do anything because i
followed the one option is what i did
even look at some of these companies
that went to the highest level they
started off with one product then when
they got big they started going this way
so the message i want to give to you
today sometimes when you have a lot of
options you actually don't decide my
yacht broker today we started off with
three odds i had made a decision on what
to buy i'm this close we go to make a
decision then he sends me three new
yacht names then i have to go back and
research what these new yacht companies
are boom i make a decision i go look at
these yachts we spend seven hours
looking at boats
this is the one i like he said but let's
look at this other one i'm like this
guy's driving me and saying love the guy
he's probably gonna watch this i love
the guy every day i get three more
options three more so now i've got my
mba i've got a bachelor's degree on all
these names of yachts that i don't want
to learn about all these different
yachts i just want a simple boat to take
me spend time with the family go hang
out water skiing jump out have drinks
have conversations have a cigar with
couple friends that's what i want to do
but because i've had so many different
options he's presented to me i haven't
made my decision yet so not only does it
not work
in your personal life if you want to
maximize your capacity but it also
doesn't work when you give your clients
too many options of a product to buy
having said that if this message made
sense to you give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you've
never seen the video i did six mistakes
sales people make if you've never
watched that before click over to watch
that video have a great one everybody
take care bye
[Music]